[Musique]
le Népal n'est plus le paradis des
randonneurs et des touristes en mal de
grands
espaces le royaume est le théâtre d'une
guerre civile ignorée mais pourtant sans
merci au pays natal de Bouddha
aujourd'hui on
égorge le roi janendra héritier de la
dynastie des chats affronte des rebelles
maoistes
fanatiques 15000 combattants qui n'ont
qu'un seul objectif renverser la
monarchie si le roi n'accepte pas nos
conditions il faut qu'il
parte 23 millions de népalais sont pris
en otage entre l'armée et les
rebelles les maoistes nous disent de ne
pas aider ces chiens du
gouvernement au milieu de la tourmente
et malgré les menaces un françaisan abu
tente d'aider la population naise il
sont en train de gêner le gouvernement
par tous les moyens et ger les
villageois par T les moyens il accepte
de me guider au pied de l'Himalaya en
plein cœur du
conflit C mandou un nom mythique qui
fait toujours rêver une destination
initiatique pour des milliers de jeunes
et pour des alpinistes en quête
d'exploit
aujourd'hui la capitale du Népal est
désertée par les touristes la ville est
sous haute surveillance l'armée
patrouille 24 he sur 24 pour tenter de
déjouer les attentats
maoistes Jean-Louis a débarqué au Népal
il y a 15 ans à l'époque il était
photographe professionnel face au
dénuement de la population il a décidé
d'aider les plus
pauvres à présent il parle népalais et
il connaît tout le monde même les Sadou
les gardiens mand
tempou Jean-Louis a ouvert une agence de
randonnée avec les bénéfices il a bâti
un dispensaire et une école dans la
montagne ce matin nous l'accompagnons à
son dispensaire la route est longue 7h
et le trajet dangereux les maoistes sont
partout dans le pays mais ces malades
ont besoin de lui on a augmenté
énormément le nombre de patients parce
que tous les dispensaires de la région
complètement disparu soit ils ont été
plastiqués soit ils ont été fermés par
moin que de moyen pas de contrôle de
l'armée pas de barrage Maoist les
premières heures se passent sans
encombreà on est à chemin du dispensaire
il y a que du goudron là nous maintenant
on prend des chemins de terre au bout
d'une heure de route 1 he de de route on
se retrouvera en zone de non droit on se
retrouvera dans une zone qui est ni ni
maoïste totalement ni ni
gouvernemental une zone de non droit où
les maoistes peuvent attaquer à
n'importe quel moment les maoistes
tiennent la moitié du pays grâce actions
spontanées voilà il tiennent la moitié
du pays par des petits action de
commando qui se pr dans autre qui sont
toujours un petit peu sanglantes souvent
surtout quand il cherchent quelqu'un
quelqu'un qui soite à à mouchardé
ilhésite pas il attrape pas n'importe où
il lu coupe la Gor
les gorges souvent ils ont pas tellement
de munition donc c'est plutôt les
gorges dans les villages la misère est
partout au Népal plus de 50 % de la
population vit au-dessous du seuil de
pauvreté l'espérance de vie ne dépasse
pas 58 ans un terro favorable pour les
maoistes qui recrutent jusque dans les
hameau les plus reculés VI comme
su av des ma par exemple on sa pas il y
en a automatique hein il y en a
automatiquement qui sont là-haut qui
sont là derrière qui qui viennent le
soir qui repartent des rebelles qui
agissent par petit groupe très mobiles
difficile pour l'armée de combattre un
ennemi aussi
insaisissable est-ce qu'il arrive que
l'armée puisse arriver à l'improviste
oui mais ils sont là l'armée ils sont à
1 heure même
pas après il patrouill au long de la
route oui là on va voir on risque de
voir des patrouilles là et puis là-bas
ilst un poste très
important arriv à ce poste tout le monde
descend les bus sont systématiquement
arrêtés et les passagers fouillés g à
ceux qui essaient de sortir
[Musique]
durant ici tout le monde s'exécute
chacun peut être suspecté d'être maoïste
et les arrestations arbitraires ne
manquent
pas les maoes cachent des explosifs dans
les coffres des véhicules à l'insu des
conducteurs contrreleur
d'autobus ils essaient de tromper notre
[Applaudissements]
vigilance parfois ils viennent sans
armes et c'est quand par hasard on
trouve des documents dans leur sac qu'on
les
démasque on peut alors les
arrêterette pas de suspect nous pouvons
reprendre notre route jusqu'au
dispensaire encore 2h si tout va bien un
barrage de la guerrie amaoist est
toujours à craindre dans le bus les
passagers sont
silencieux terminus de la ligne
jaltum c'est ici que Jean-Louis a
construit son dispensaire il y a une
dizaine
d'années voilà arrivé au
village ici Jean-Louis est un homme
respecté tout le monde le connaî on
l'appelle cha mon
oncle et quand il vient dans son village
ne manque jamais de saluer cette jeune
femme voilà alors la dame qu'on vient de
filmer est une infirmière d'un
dispensaire qui était à 1 heure de chez
nous et qui a été fermé par les ma donc
elle est là vend des médicaments alors
c'est une excellente infirmière et
excellente gynéco que tu crois n parler
non rien que là VI de me
dire on se reverra pour
parler le dispensaire est à l'écart du
village en dépit du CAL appar les
rebelles ne sont pas loin TR de leur
présence sont partout c'est la route qui
se termine là au bout en attendant
qu'une autre soit construite mais les
travaux sont arrêtés depuis à peu près
un an au moins il renonne donc les
entreprises et donc les entreprises
s'arrêtent petit à petit un Raquet
systématique les pelles mécaniques ont
été brûlé l'entreprise avait refusé de
payer l'impôt
révolutionnaire quand il y a eu le
blocus il av mis des affiches comme ça
partout disant il faut pas bouger restez
chez vous gens
obligé obligé si vous en tuez un ou deux
sur le chemin c'est fini il y a plus
personne qui bouge en fin de journée
Jean-Louis arrive à son
[Musique]
dispensaire voilà notre royaume donc
j'ai une chambre àou un grand royaume
ici donc aujourd'hui on
soigner
personnes année plus plus de 20000
malades viennent se faire soigner
ici nous avons beaucoup de problèmes
pulmonaires et puis on a beaucoup de
brûlures aussi brure c'est suivant les
saisons ça c'est maintenant que ça va
commencer parce que les gens restent
assis autour d'un d'un réchaud qui est
gonflé avec pression et qui explose de
temps en temps et donc on a les gosses
surtout qui sont premier plan qui sont
brûlés en plus de
dispensire
ens de 5 à
S c'est l'association de Jean-Louis qui
finance cette école gratuite pour tous
les
[Musique]
élèves je sais pas si c'est être MAE
mais l'école gratuite l'hôpital gratuit
mais nous ça fait on a commencé il y a
bien longtemps on a commencé il y a 12
ans alors que ont commencé il y a que 6
ans donc on a peut-être été maist avant
eux les enfants sont parfois témoins de
la guerre qui se déroule autour
d'eux près de l'école là il a abattu un
garçon 18 20 ans à peu près qui
considéit comme voleur ou quelque chose
comme ça ils nous ont obligé à laisser
le corps devant l'école pendant 3 jours
et toute la population a du défiler
devant les écoliers aussi les écoliers
aussi mais où sont donc ces rebelles
maoïist pour parvenir jusqu'à eux je
vais changer de guide j'ai rendez-vous
le lendemain avec matrika un journaliste
népalais arrêté plusieurs fois par la
police les autorités le soupçonnent
d'être proche des
révolutionnaires matrika a accepté de me
conduire dans son village perdu dans la
montagne en pleine zone rebelle
direction plein S
en chemin des carcasses de voiture
calciné lorsque la guerria décide le
blocus de la capitale personne n'a le
droit de rouler le mois dernier les
maoistes ont décrété de jours de grève
mais certains ont quand même voulu
circuler les Mao leur ont demandé de
descendre de cet autobus et il l'ont
brûlé à charicotte l'atmosphère devient
tendu j'aperçois une colonne d'hom en
arm bizarrement vêtu visiblement fatigué
d'avoir marché
ourille pouroi ces hommes sontil
civil lorsque les militaires sont en
patrouille ils évitent désormais de
porter la ten de combat ils civil hab
comme des
[Musique]
ma lorsquil rent dans les villages il
demande aux habitants où sont nos amis
nous sommes ma nous venons de tel
endroit et notre commandant nous a
ordonné de rencontrer nos camarades
au sommet d'un col l'armée a installé un
barrage où elle contrôle tous les
voyageurs dans ce poste les soldats sont
même retranchés derrière des sacs de
sable j'essaie de me faire passer pour
un touriste mais je n'y échappe pas je
dois sortir mon
passeport évez votre nom je m'exécute
dans ce for les militaires sont nerveux
et la caméra est indésirable et toi pas
d'image
maintenant nous sommes à J après nous
devrons
marcher c'est la dernière de l'É
oui c'est le dernier po de l'armée
royale du
Népal après il a plus et commence la
zoneh matin le lè suronde
deous point de départ des randonnées
pour
l'Himalaya avec nos porteurs et notre
guide personne ne prête attention à nous
qui pourrait se douter que le but de
notre expédition n'est pas d'approcher
les neiges éternelles mais la
Guer pour y arriver un seul moyen le
tracteur et sa
remorque moyen gagner presque une
journée grâce au tracteur la piste
sarrête plus loin et au passe mais là
grâce au tracteur on peut avancer au
moins 4 km he donc plus vite que
piedg nous allons traverser la rivière
kimti et après nous marcherons à travers
la
forêt les ponts comme les routes sont
rares les Népal se déplac à pied c'est
un handicap pour l'armée mais un
avantage pour les rebelles en perpétuel
mouvement et capable de marcher 10 he
par jour en portant 50
kg à partir d'ici toute autorité a
disparu la région est sous la coupe des
groupes
armés cette inscription est un slogan
maoistste on peut lire que pour rendre
plus forte la République du Népal le
marxisme le léninisme et le maoisme avo
une longue
vie mon allure est trop lente Matri veut
arriver chez lui avant la nuit nous
décidons de continuer à cheval au Népal
ils sont rares leur valeur est
inestimable un paysan accepte de me
louer le sien mais pas question pour lui
de se séparer de sa monture il nous
accompagne et il tient lui-même la bride
pour guider son cheval dans les
rochers
enfin nous touchons au but là tu voas la
maison avec le drapau rouge et disons
que le fils à le
patron lui il travaille dans le
militaire pour le gouvernement c'est
pour ça que maintenant les ma ils l'ont
capturé cette maision et ils l'ont dit
la famille de quitter le
village nous pénétrons avec précaution
dans le hameau à première V personne les
maoistes inspirent une telle crainte
qu'il leur suffit de planter un drapeau
rouge sur un toit pour que les habitants
obéissent au doigt et à
[Musique]
l'œil les rebelles ne sont pas loin mais
matrika lui n'a pas peur il est ici chez
lui notre arrivée n'est pas passé
inaperçu je suis persuadé que les
rebelles sont déjà est arrivé au
village à la nuit tombée matrika
réapparaît il n'est pas seul il revient
avec le commissaire politique du secteur
un des chefs maoistes les plus
importants de la
région il s'appelle boud paudel comme
beaucoup de cadres du mouvement il était
auparavant instituteur et communiste
avant de rejoindre le Maqui sa tête est
mise à prix mais il sait que dans ce
village il est en
sécurité
qu'est-ce que vous voulez imposer avec
Leme
nép notre but est d'arriver au
communisme mais nous savons que ce n'est
pas possible dans l'immédiat au Népal
c'est pourquoi nous voulons que le pays
soit d'abord gouverné non pas selon des
lois estcté par le roi mais par une
constitution écrite par le
peuplei est que est-ce que lui aussi
dans les
réunions la population il par de la même
manière
oui car le roira affiche lui aussi ce
type d'attitude dans les villages
beaucoup de gens rien à mangeris que les
reven du rougment de plus en plus ce roi
est un ancien
industriel c'est aussi un trafiant sans
compter qu'il a reçu l'héritage de son
frère déf mais ça ne lui suffit pas il
en veut toujours
plus dans les tribunaux populaires
est-ce que le tribunal populaire a déjà
prononcé la peine de mort contre des
collaborateurs du
Couvernement bien sûr oui mais nous
tuons seulement ceux qui sont contre
notre guerre par exemple si quelqu'un
alerte l'armée de la présence des
maoistes si quelqu'un nous espionne on
l'exécute comment procédez-vous comment
on les exécute nous avons eu un cas très
récent pas loin d'ici mes amis maoistes
avaient arrêté un espion il lui on
tranché la gorge avec un poignard
lorsquil s'agit d'espion il n a pas de
pitié l'entretien est terminé B se
cacher interdiction de le suivre le chef
Rebel est prudent il sait que la nuit
l'armée patrouille dans les
montagnes ce soir le sousliant B est en
mission avec section il tra les groupes
arm
dans les villages la population assiste
effrayée à ces incursions
nocturnes ce soir les rebelles ne sont
pas au rendez-vous la patrouille prend
le chemin du
retourra bataille contre un autre pays
est très facile mais lorsquon se bat
contre des terroristes c'est très dur de
trouver la bonne tactique nous menons
une guerre
difficile une guerre difficile comme le
montr ces images tourné par l'armée
népalaise
plus de 10000 morts en 9 ans une guerre
sans pitié ni témoin sur les contrefors
de
l'Himalaya les soldats déterent les
corps de leurs ennemis pour les exhiber
comme des
trophées malgré les risques les maoes
n'ésit pas organiser de grands
rassemblements comme le montr ces images
filmé par Matri le journaliste népalais
en septembre dernier 3500 rebelles se
sont réunis dans le district
d'acha sur ce document exceptionnel les
rebelles apparaissent au grand jour et à
visage
découvert au 21e siècle il y a toujours
l'impérialisme américain qui en tant que
puissance mondiale détruit les êtres
humains mais la population du monde
entier en regardant vers le Népal en
regardant vers nos montagnes sont en
train de se dire qu'un monde heureux est
en pass de naître grâce à notre présence
sous la direction victorieuse du parti
maoiste et du commandement suprême de
l'armée du peuple
ce jour-là ils ont organisé une
démonstration de force les maoistes ont
divisé le pays en trois régions
militaires ils sont capables d'aligner
15000 hommes en armes sur le
terrain les femmes participent au combat
ce sont elles dit-on les plus farouches
soudain un hélicoptère de l'armée vient
jouer les troubles
[Musique]
fait
dans la vallée voisine un groupe de
combattants regarde le spectacle offert
par la section de propagande les femmes
sont chargées de chanter la gloire de la
révolution en
[Musique]
marche
pourquoi j'ai suivi les ma un de mes
grands frères est tombé en martyr et
j'ai pensé que je pouvais venger son
sang en adhérant au parti j'ai été
intégré dans la brigade culturelle j'ai
ans n'est pas la plus jeune les enfants
soldats sont nombreux dans les groupes
armés 30 % au moins de 18 ans le parti a
annoncé qu'il comptait lever une brigade
de 50000
adolescents retour à
catmandou je me rends dans un orphelina
où sont recueillis quelquesuns de ses
ex-enfants soldats qui ont réussi à
échapper à l'emprise des maoistes
aujourd'hui les bénévoles de
l'association chandro DAA essaie de leur
donner un peu de
chaleur sur les murs des photographies
d'enfant dispar
les éducateurs en reçoivent des dizaines
chez les rebelles les petits kidnappés
ont subi un véritable lavage de
cerveau c'est qui tous ces enfants des
enfants qui ont eu des problèmes avec
les maoistes seulement avec
Maoist qu-ce arrivé
toi les maoistes m'ont emmené de force
je ne voulais pas les suivre mais ils
m'ont traîné par les bras mes parents
pleuraient les ma m'ont obligé à marcher
très longtemps longtemps dans la
forêt il avec eux dans la
forêt ils m'ont obligé à transporter une
grosse boule très très grosse c'était
une bombe c'était très lourd j'avais
beaucoup de mal à la
porter en fait ila les munitions il pait
ça toute la
montagne et ensuite qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé
on a mangé ils ont fait une sieste et
dans la nuit on est descendu jusqu'à un
village ils ont frappé à la porte d'une
échope le commerçant est sorti et ils
l'ont braqué avec un fusil en lui
mettant une main sur la bouche ils lui
ont volé son argent et ils l'ont
[Musique]
tué
lui oui j'ai beaucoup crié ils m'ont mis
à moi aussi la main devant la bouche
comme avec le commerçant
[Musique]
ché 17h l'heure du repas du soir au
milieu de ses nouveaux amis Krishna a
l'impression d'appartenir à une famille
alorphelina il mange à sa faim reste ses
cauchemars qui le H chaque
[Musique]
nuit aujourd'hui c'est
IKA une fête sacrée que tout le monde
respecte au
Népal Jean-Louis est revenu spécialement
à catemandou pour bénir ses employés
Latic c'est le jour le plus important en
Népal où les parents donneent la
bénédiction au plus jeunes et à cette
occasion donc on fait un vœ pour que
dans l'année de l'argent
arrive
un peu plus loin et malgré la menace
maoistste des milliers de personnes
attendent devant les grilles du palais
en ce grand jour tous ceux qui le
désirent peuvent approcher le
[Musique]
roi la cour d'honneur est ouverte
exceptionnellement au public beaucoup
sont venus de très loin pour demander la
bénédiction de Sa Majesté
[Musique]
janendra attendez depuis longtemps
depuis 2
ou d' attend depuis 4 le roendra apparaî
enfin devant ses sujets le protocole est
très strict même les rayons du soleil ne
doivent pas incommoder Sa Majesté à s
côtés les deux piliers du régime le
ministre de l'Intérieur et le chef
d'étatmajor de
l'armée militaires et policiers sont les
premiers à se présenter devant leur
souverin que les plus dévau considèent
comme une
[Musique]
divinité
derrière suivent les plus humbles les
paralytique qui espè remarcher un jour
grâce à l'onction royale arriv ensuite
les
SAD je suis moiême invité à m'incliner
devant celui que les ma veulent
abattre
dans une salle à part c'est la reine qui
donne la bénédiction aux
[Musique]
femmesp oui bien s chacun le
RO j'ai pourant lu dans les journau
qu'il y a des problèmes dans le pays ça
c'est autre chose c'est
différent c'est un problème politique
vous savez le Népal a été Bâ par les
rois c'est pourquoi nous les aimons tout
le monde ici aime la
monarchie vous voulez la monarchie oui
vous voulez pas un changer non non
jamais jamais on adore notre
roi un soutien sans faille des partisans
du roi qui s'inclinent devant
l'oriflamme pourpre de la dynastie des
chats à l'inverse des rebelles
maoiststes qui rêv d'abattre la
monarchie en pénétrant un jour armes à
la main dans le palais interdit